If you're a pet parent like me,
and a lot of you guys are!
(audience cheering)
That's right!
Makes me so happy there's so many of us here in this room.
And for those who are watching,
you know what a challenge it can be
to keep your furry friends fresh and clean, no joke.
And that's why I was so excited to team up with PetSmart
and introduce my dogs, Douglas and Lucy,
to their top groomers.
Take a look.
Hi, guys.
[Ashley And Kristie] Hi.
How are you?
Good, how are you?
So nice to meet you guys.
We are so excited to meet Lucy and Douglas today.
This is Lucy, and that's Douglas.
And they're very much in love.
They've been together almost nine years now.
Aw.
Best friends too, you can tell.
Yeah, they're very different dogs.
They have very different coats.
Lucy's hair, it's so grody from the New York City streets.
What is your advice on how often
I should groom Lucy?
I would recommend probably every four to six weeks
for more of a FURminator treatment.
'Cause you wanna get that undercoat out,
'cause she looks like she sheds a lot.
But it's more than just the FURminator,
it's really the whole process.
The brush, specialized shampoo, conditioner and a blowout.
So really get that undercoat out
'cause that's also what's gonna attract a lot of that dirt.
So I brought the FURminator with me.
And so do you want me to show you how to use it?
I mean, I have four cats, two dogs,
six chickens, a bearded dragon.
Oh, and a fish named Blueberry.
My house is kind of covered in animal hair.
So is this a solution?
Yes, definitely, because I'm sure
you probably can't wear black pants a lot.
Oh, I mean, if I was a human lint roller,
that would help.
What you do is you just go along the growth
and not a lot of pressure.
See all that hair?
But see all
this stuff coming out?
(Kristie laughing)
That's with three strokes.
And in the salon, like Ashley said,
they'll get the full treatment.
So it's the shampoo, the conditioner,
drying, as well as the brushing.
You could go to the salon.
What does it take to become a groomer at a PetSmart?
Oh gosh, it's such a commitment.
Most all of our stylists start out as a bather
and they work their way up through our training program,
over 800 hours of classroom time with hands-on training
to learn all different types of dogs, breed knowledge.
And you have to be so passionate
about animals to do what we do.
because you take all kinds.
And we don't just groom dogs in our salons,
we also groom cats and felines.
What about bearded dragons?
Because Jeremy, if you think I've got dry legs,
you should meet Jeremy.
We don't do bearded dragon grooming yet,
but maybe in the future.
You never know.
I'm telling you.
I mean, I love that it takes that long
to train to become a groomer
so that the customer and the owner feel so safe.
I mean, we've been with PetSmart a long time.
Like this is my 20th year with the company.
And Kristie has been with us.
14 years now.
And she's also our top 10 member for Groom Team USA.
I am.
Okay, but then what do you recommend for Douglas?
I would recommend our HEMPZ Package,
which is a really good shampoo, conditioning treatment,
you wanna add moisture back into that coat.
I'd also do nail grinding,
which helps keep the nails really nice,
and short, and smooth so that if he jumps up,
won't scratch the kids
or keeps them nice and short
around the house on hardwood floors.
This is a Dremel, but it has a special head on it for dogs.
So it does make the nail warm or hot,
it's just the vibration that feels a little funny.
Well, I would like some of that.
Feels really nice.
So now that we've brushed them out and done some stuff,
we have our summer collection of bandanas here.
Would you like to pick out something for each of them?
It's gonna be hard to choose because I'm so into them.
But yeah.
I think I'm gonna go for these two.
No shocker here, I'm gonna go with the flowers.
It's my fave.
And then, I'm definitely
going with the popsicle motif,
because these are just sparking a lot of joy.
(upbeat music)
I mean, look at them!
Oh, that whole segment I was like,
"Look at that dog, look at that dog."
I just wanna give a huge thank you
to Ashley and Kristie from PetSmart
for showing me all the amazing services they offer.
And if you wanna pamper your furry friends,
head over to PetSmart.com to book a grooming
or just a walk-in for a standalone service.
And we want our studio audience to get in on all the fun,
so you're all going home
with a $100 gift card from PetSmart!
(audience cheering)
(upbeat music)